So, last week we posted some photos on our
Facebook page showing a pile of rubbish that
was dumped near the Kaiapoi River.
Most of you were pretty upset about it, and
rightly so, it's disgusting and we all have
to pay to clean it up.
So we've recreated a trailer load of rubbish
similar to what was found near the Kaiapoi River.
We've got stuff in here like a baby car seat,
a mattress, a kitchen benchtop, an oven,
a sneaker, some polystyrene and just some other
bits and pieces similar to what was found.
So we're going to take this trailer load of
rubbish through the Southbrook Resource Recovery Park
and show just how inexpensive it is to
deal with rubbish properly.
So we're at our first stop in the recycling
area and we're going to get rid of the oven.
Items like ovens can be dropped off for free
at the scrap metal and whiteware section.
Cardboard and polystyrene can also be recycled
for free.
Also shown in the photos was a baby car seat.
You can now bring these to the Resale Store
and recycle them for just $5.
It's much cheaper than taking it into Christchurch
to recycle and it doesn't matter what condition
it is in or even if it's expired, it's still
just $5.
If the mattress and benchtop were in good
condition, these could also be dropped off
to the Resale Store.
And so we'll take the rest of the stuff through
to the refuse area.
So, total cost: $36, really easy
and most of the stuff we brought along was
able to be recycled.